the first two parts what is the
multi-armed bandit problem whatever it's
different variation what's the main tool
to privatize this and how people do that
but then hopefully a few news the new
things not really difficult but
interesting should be at least
interesting lower bounds for the problem
with the coupling lemma from Havana and
an optimal algorithm for the
multivariate problem and I'll talk about
them why is it optimal also the nifty
side problem of the private stopping
point and finally maybe a little bit of
moral to the story okay so let's start
motivate the problem in a real life
story our ingenious doctors came up with
key new treatments and now we want to
determine which one is best for a
certain condition so we're faced with
this stream of animated sick kids and we
want to give them an animated medicine
and we're going to do it sequentially
they're gonna come one by one non
adversary in an iid fashion and we're
gonna choose which treatment we're gonna
give them see whether they are turning
into healthy animated kid or dead
animated kid and the point here is this
is sequential choice based on what
happened in the past I need to make a
choice how to treat the next sick
animated kid obviously I didn't do
animation here because I'm lazy and
because googling sick yeah or dead
animated kids is weird anyway the point
is this we have an algorithm the choose
is based on the past how to treat the
next patient and then with you the
outcome our goal is that at the end of
this long sequence it has T samples
we're gonna count how many people died
how many people it want to minimize the
number of death animated it apparently
people are sensitive about you know
condition of tiny oming so what does it
start with this iid mean then the the
sequence of rewards is going to be drawn
independently okay even though you're
basing the decision for the next child
on the reason my choice exactly my
choice depends on the history but the
reward is drawn independently each time
okay this is not an adversarial setting
to generalize we are faced with this K
slot machines each one has an arm and I
choose which one to pull each one is
going to rob me something else hence the
name multi-armed and bandits because
they're going to take some of money
eventually
but each reward is drawn from its own
distribution with its own mean and my
goal is to choose which arm to pull next
in the next iteration over every new day
or every new time step yeah the reward
once I pull it's only determined based
on the arm that I chose to pull okay my
objective is to maximize the total
reward over all T days since we are
computer scientists with glue mentality
we're think of minimizing the loss how
much am I losing because I do not know a
priori what are these means
had I known these means are priori which
one would I choose every day the best
one the one with the highest name
because I do not know because I have to
figure that out on my own
I'm incurring some loss and we're going
to look at the expected loss or the
expected regret for not knowing things
that is the maximum reward that I could
have gotten from a drop - what I
actually got from that drop when I did
not pull the right arm
okay so this problem despite its
simplicity is very very ubiquitous and
learning and reinforcement learning when
an angel deals with an unfamiliar
unfamiliar environment because it's the
basic problem that combines these two
problems of learning which is
exploration versus exploitation I've
just pulled arm three I got a certain
reward should I pull a different arm and
hope to get a different a better reward
that will be the exploration part of my
learning I just pulled on three and got
a nifty reward I want to continue
pulling it because it's a pretty high
reward that'll be the exploitation part
I just did something good I want to
repeat the way to trade the two in
general is this approach something that
I read about in book it's called
optimism optimism in the face of
uncertainty that is the motive for
people who are dealing with these kind
of problems and let's explain one
problem after another what it means okay
so here we are with our K bandits we
have pulled them a bunch of times we
have empirical means for the rewards we
got from each pool of each arm we are
working with statisticians and
statisticians tell us that the means are
not everything we need to draw a
confidence interval around that mean to
tell us where the actual mean of the arm
is likely to be and what we're going to
be in our optimistic about to say well
the best thing can happen the best thing
the actual reward is going to be the
upper confidence bound of each arm
that's what I'm going to postulate based
on that I'm going to pull the arm with
the largest upper confidence bar and
then I pull it and I see one of two
things maybe it is the right arm I
should be getting a high reward
push that confidence upper bound above
or it's a bad arm
I should be pulling it down and then
making potentially a different arm
marginally better then I pulled the
other
this upper confidence bond comes from
immediate bounds on the length of their
confidence bound from basic statistics
one over the number of pulls this is my
exploration bonus I get the actual mean
but then I'm adding up based on my
optimistic approach of yes it'd be
worthwhile to explore this arm turns out
that this algorithm gives me the regret
bound that I'm after which is
logarithmic in the knife in the length
of the sequence over the sub optimality
gap of each sub optimal arm that means
the difference in the mean between the
actual one the best one and the arm that
I just pulled now what you don't see
here is basically this is squared times
Delta I is Delta I squared in the
denominator that's the number of poles
of each sub-optimal arms I'm going to be
making times Delta I because each time
that I pull this of optimal are my loss
is not one my loss is just this about
the malakut turns out that this is also
optimal there are lower bounds match
this upper bar okay
let's turn to a variant of this problem
linear bandits the main the main benefit
of this variant is that in the previous
setting each reward tells you only on
the mean of that particular arm and
gives you no information about any other
arms and the basic way that people
assume that pulling one arm tells me
something of the reward of other arms is
to put all arms in the Euclidean plane
there is sub sorry not the plane you're
clearly in space there is some decision
set which is a bunch of vectors in the
plane in space and then how is my reward
drawn each time I choose an arm the will
there is some unknown vector out there
theta star and the reward from pulling
our teeth our X is going to be the
projection of the arm on to theta theta
star my unknown parameter plus noise
yet again how do we known favor star in
advance we would know what to pull in
each and every time the arm with the
largest projection on data star we don't
know so we're facing with a regret
problem and the rebirth problem summing
over all time sequences the best arm the
difference and because of linearity just
pushes into the dot part ok what is
optimism in linear bandits well while
they're multiple approach here is the
more canonical one we are going to
construct a confidence set of where thus
unknown vector theta star is likely to
be and now we're going to be extremely
optimistic for each arm we're going to
say what is this best vector in my
confidence that is likely they have them
sorry that has the highest projection
and that will be the upper confidence
bound for that arm so we're really
optimistic we're taking for each arm a
separate vector
so what is this confidence but the
confidence Bank is going to be a lip
sword it's going to be essentially a
ball disturbed ball but according to
Samuel and all this distance but what
are these two parameters that determine
my the way I measure distances and
radius of small the ellipse sorry there
is a closed formula of what will be the
exploration bonus for each arm so how do
I derive this particular the particular
center of the ball the way I measure
distances and the range of that ball
well
I do what I'm supposed to do this theta
star basically is going to be the most
likely solution that gives me the
prediction of these rewards that I've
received and that is something a
regression problem so I look at all the
arms that I've pulled up to now all the
rewards that I've gotten up to now and I
solve the linear regression problem that
gives me the center of the ellipsoid set
turns out that the center again has this
closed form by the inverse of this
matrix times this vector they call this
matrix VT the second moment matrix of
all the features of all the arms that
I've pulled thus far and UT the vector
of the projected rewards and the
multiplication between the inverse of V
T times G of T gives me that center
point and moreover V T tells me how to
measure my distances how to change the
distances so basically if the reward is
sample from Gaussian I'm simplifying
everything then the estimated reward
versus the actual reward factor they're
going to be distributed one around the
other like a certain like a certain
multi-dimensional Gaussian and the rain
and the distance between them is going
to be distributed like a chi square I
can work out and get the right beta T
okay and again you can also work out
what will be the closed form expression
for the use the upper confidence bound
of each arm
the key point that I wanna make the
butcher will be relevant for the rest of
the talk is that when making this
decision all of the history depends
solely on this VT the second moment
matrix of the arms that I just pull that
I pulled up to today and UT the
projected rewards up to today contextual
bandit are an extension even further of
this where I'm also putting into my
reinforcement learning problem an
adversarial portion that is each person
comes and tells me a certain context my
set of actions is the same set of
actions but based on the context and the
action the reward is going to be drawn
the way people model it more often than
not is that they assume there is some
feature map they got it out of sheer
inspiration that feature map Maps the
context and an action to a vector and
now we have a linear bandit problem but
the key point is that every day based on
the context I might be getting a
different set of vectors the set of
actions are the same but the mapping is
changes basis our changes based on the
context and therefore I'm going to get a
different set of vectors which makes the
alternative model even simpler it's
linear bandit with a changing set of
actions in each day and that set of
changing action is basically provided to
me by the teeth sample they regard in
this context the expected regret is the
now the maximum in each day's decision
set of the same expression are you
saying these two problems are like an
equivalent mathematically or these are
two generalizations of the linear
problem well this doesn't say anything
about linearity but if I assume this and
linearity then their equipment okay
because this basically tells me how I
get this decision set and this one tells
me well someone gives my decision set so
the context mapping is just
a set of vectors ignore Nvidia and so
the context is given to you it's not
saving additionally you're trying to
infer it's given to me but it's given to
any adversary I have no no iid
distribution on the context
so this concludes the intro to the
reinforcement learning problem I'm going
to talk about how to make all of these
algorithms for the different problems
how to make them differentially prac so
the first thing I need to clarify this
what is the notion of privacy I'm
working with and that is event labor
event less privacy okay we're going to
talk about two sequences of rewards as a
chaser as neighboring if they differ on
the reward of a single arm support the
privacy however they want to preserve is
for with respect to the output of the
algorithm and the output of the
algorithm is the sequence of pull
throughout all days so we want in the
entire sequence the probability of any
sequence of action does not change
drastically when only the reward of a
single arm changes even if it that we
reward happen to be on day one and
potentially affects the entire seasons
and the caveat here is that we're going
to talk only about e to the X on pure
differential privacy know epsilon yup
that's it's not let's make it
okay how do we achieve this again I told
you but this is gonna be boring the tree
based mechanism of China now and pork
you know it allows us to count partial
sums in a stream like fashion but
there's a purpose why we're doing this
we kept even though I drew the tree like
nature by mistake rather than top-down I
did it bottom-up okay so the idea of the
tree based mechanism
each node stores the sum of all the
datums in its subtree so in particular
this one should store a noisy count of 6
a private count of the sum of the
entries below
note that each datum effects at most log
key counters from the leaf to the root
therefore we need to budget our epsilon
differential privacy budget goes in each
counter epsilon over log T to count how
many what is the sum of all rewards from
day 1 up to a certain day T there is a
combination of no more than log T
counters that we can add up therefore
the variance in the count in each
counter variance is log T squared over
epsilon squared and I'm multiplying this
by log T if you want a Union bound then
you get yet to add another log T so the
cow the crux of this is that we have
something that counts all partial reward
up to poly log T over epsilon err
and that's it basically the to privatize
the read the these problems of
multi-armed bandit you just plug in the
shoe based mechanism okay
that is what Mishra and the CUDA did and
- so in the middle caucus sleep okay we
have the UCB algorithm the explore range
the exploration bonus is independent of
the rewards that I've seen but the
impatient reward clearly depends on all
the rewards that I've seen what I'm
going to do is to apply the tree based
mechanism to maintain a private count of
that mint and the cumulative error if we
have to maintain for each arm a tree of
polity length it's going to be the same
non private bound plus K times our poly
log over apps are poly log T over a
number of ups
it's meeting leaders people is there any
questions about it are there
to apply this to the linear vendors we
do the exact same thing remember we need
to solve a regression problem that
regression problem is just the result of
a matrix times a vector right our matrix
times a vector we apply the tree based
mechanism to this matrix and to this
vector we update the confidence bound by
the by the fact that we have noisy
estimation how much they can affect we
need some regularization there are
issues to be involved but that's the
idea
and for contextual bandit it's also
going to be the same subject to one
major caveat because if we want to have
a differentially private algorithm that
also masks the context in each day then
our regret has to be linear there is a
very simple counter example there are
two arms a and B there is one context
setting the reward of r1 to be there
more for award of arm a to be one the
reward of arm B to be 0 and there's
another context that's the opposite
thing reward of arm B is now one of arm
a is 0 if I have to pull an arm and mask
the context I have to treat these two
contexts as equally likely to appear I
have to effectively play randomize
response and pull each arm with
probability at least you know third
like isn't such a setting it seems to
you to find your Dionysius same or next
comes the bull in this context can
depend on this context but must be
differentially discontent when I give
the talking sediment yeah you're welcome
because that's what we did we did define
the joint differential privacy based on
that definition because the user
provides the context I'm gonna pull an
arm that's only going to be sent to the
user but everything that I pulled to any
other user even at the end of the
sequence they come together and try to
figure out what was that that I told her
Kuna they won't be able to join
differential privacy not going to go to
the formal definition but basically if
the change happens on day t then
everything that happens in the t plus
one till the end of the sequence remains
- there is also the obscene a word of
experiments which we did and we did not
apply the Laplace we didn't apply
epsilon differential privacy if we leave
the epsilon-delta differential privacy
with different kinds of noise different
kind of instances basically it works
this is the Gaussian this the lowest one
is a differentiated private curve okay
enough of the things that you already
know now to some new stuff hopeful ok
let's talk about lower bounds for the
private problem here
is private used to be the best thing we
can do does it actually meet our lower
bound I mean how do we even go about
formulating the lower bound and here is
a beautiful beautiful tool the power of
atom coupling well we all know that if I
have an algorithm which is epsilon
differential privacy epsilon
differentially private and there are two
data sets two different data sets B 1 D
2 then any event is as likely to happen
on one and the other by this probability
of no more each to the epsilon end there
is group privacy that is standard result
from Denise and days of differential
privacy what Cohen would then showed is
that if d1 and d2 are drawn our IDs
drawn from either distribution P or
distribution Q then the probability with
respect to the data set now of an event
changes by n times the total variation
distance between P and Q there is a
beautiful coupling principle behind it
that matches these two distribution such
that only a fraction of total variation
distance between the two are actually
different samples
okay is this clear the group privacy
effectively shrinks by the total
variation distance between team also and
that's a beautiful observation from
cilia that this is optimal if I consider
the sampling algorithm then basically
the two distributions are different just
one point so it's a different way to
view implication I mean if if the
algorithm works by sampling and then
applying some say one differentially
profit algorithm you get this result
okay so now here is my claim key my
claim is that any differentially private
algorithm for the multi-armed bandit
sister it forward the simplest one with
the actual bandits themselves that is
efficient it gets sub-linear regret and
the constant here doesn't really matter
as long as T goes to infinity has to
pull any sub optimal arms number of
times which is lucky over epsilon Delta
to sub optimality is the statement clear
log numbers love log number log of the
number of samples in my stream over
epsilon times the sub optimality here
okay and here is the construction there
is going to be one set where the best
time is the reward of say half and
everything has its sub optimality gap
and then I'm going to consider arm I and
pull its reward above the leading arm
it's going to have a mean reward of half
plus Delta I this is distribution P this
will be distribution Q the total
variation distance between them is two
Delta
so step one if all the rewards of armed
I are drawn from cue the probability
that I'm pulling so few samples from the
right arm in this setting the leaning
arm is going to be polynomially small
and that is just markers because my
regret is upper bounded by the
probability of pulling it very few times
and each time I pull oh it's t over 2
times the probability so but the ignore
this part ignore the latter part the
probability that I'm pulling it very few
times times all of the regret that I'm
accumulating which is basically linear
so if my expected regret is sub linear
that's going to be 1 over some
polynomial in T the probability of
pulling an arm so few times and based on
that this is somewhat of a fickle
argument that I don't know if I'm
necessarily complicating the reasoning
or not but then we're going to decide on
an hybrid argument where the first n I
examples come from this distribution Q
and then I flip it to P and argue that
the number of pools is also going to be
small there and then we're playing the
call overdone lemma okay so what is the
this hybrid model here's my algorithm
rather than my algorithm going and
pulling it on it's going to shut over a
chasm you know hey dear friend near r1
pull my arm and tell me what reward I
got it's going to be for m1 in all arms
and let's say that for arm I we're going
to put a special light bulb that it's
going to turn on after we make at least
and I calls so we just argued that when
all draws of arm 1 are coming from Q
from that distribution where it's the
leading arm the probability that the
light remains off is polynomially small
and because the views up to the pool and
I are exactly the same then also in this
hybrid model this is going to happen now
notice that in the hybrid model I have
no idea what the algorithm does maybe it
runs some weird complicated thing maybe
it applies rachels
detection mechanism and this census of
detections is okay I'm going to stop and
go solve the Riemann hypothesis we don't
know what the algorithm is supposed to
do on this weird thing but because we
chose to change only the first n dipoles
then the view is exactly the same up to
and I with the view over at setting
where everything comes from Q and it
doesn't it doesn't apply if I'm changing
some intermediate and I pull that's what
I find surprising for someone maybe I'm
over complicating things okay and now we
apply to this hybrid the car over the
new privacy arguing that if on the
hybrid the probability is polynomially
small well then epsilon times ni times
the total variation distance between P
and Q makes the prop the problems the
light going off under distribution where
everything comes from peak at most half
can I pass the threshold of that and
then we're done okay basically it says
that my expected regret has to be K
block the over epsilon because with
probability of at most sorry at least
1/2 the light goes on I pulled it at
least ni times and each of these ni
times I incur an expected repair of
Delta I and then there holds for each
and every aren't suboptimal
Christian's
so here's always them
none privately the UCB is optimal it has
the right upper bound
it matches the lower bar none privately
the addition of the additional cost in
the upper bound it's cave poly log T
over epsilon and in the lower bound its
case trick log T over epsilon and
despite the fact that I'm needed
I care for the remainder of this talk
about the fact that here I have a poly
log and here I have a lock the added
cost because of privacy here is pull
poly log in T and here is 3 o'clock T
and the question is which one of them is
true paint the lower one the second one
that's the right upper bound also but in
order to get to an algorithm that
achieves an A an expected regret of all
of this term of both of these terms it
should be clear based on my lengthy
discussion on the tree based mechanism
that we cannot use the tree based
mechanism at least not as is because as
is the standard deviation is strictly
greater than log T so it boils down to
an algorithmic question we need to
change the algorithm to our algorithm to
a different algorithm that solves the
problem of multi-armed bandit successive
elimination also a fault or algorithm
even Darmon all months formalized it but
I think it was known prior to basically
it works in iterations in around in each
round it pulls all the arms that are
still optional still in the game and
then at the end of the round looks has
there hasn't been an arm which is
noticeably suboptimal respect to
different arm if so I'll eliminate it
noticeably means twice the hafting bout
and that's achieved the same asymptotic
regret as the UCB
outer its equivalent to the used to be
Oliver as I'm talking okay so how do we
make this algorithm private let's start
with an easier case a thought experiment
suppose we only have two arms if we only
have two arms if I pull on one I pull
arm to I am basically looking at the
difference of the two arms there is an
expected difference and I want to figure
out the expected difference is positive
or negative that's my goal for K equals
two
okay this allows me to cite back into
the problem of the stopping rule in the
stopping rule problem I get an infinite
length sequence of examples simple iid
from some distribution which I do not
know my goal is to say at some point
here I'm going to stop and I'm going to
output a guess
and I want my guests to be within a
multiplicative 1 plus minus alpha factor
of the actual net in particular when
alpha is 1/2 and predicting where the
view is greater than 0 of smaller than 0
the key point is that I want a
multiplicative approximation added
additive approximation and so if mu is 0
I should go infinitely long sequence I
should take and it never stopped
the non-private way to do that is the
following non-monotonic adaptive
sampling are remembered of Domingo now
it's very simple algorithm basically
says I'm going to okay so first I have a
probability of error I'm going to decide
on the infinite sequence master on this
infinite sum and in fact my huffing
button accordingly but the point is this
I am going to halt when the magnitude of
the empirical mean of all the samples
that I've seen up to today is greater
than the huffing bang basically over
alpha and why is that
very simple because the empirical mean
and the actual mean are differ by no
more than the hafting bound and when I
stop this condition hold I hope you can
all see that this is basically the the
halting condition we awarded and when
this hold this term is no more than the
magnitude of mu and that is very simple
to see because the difference is no more
than huffing bond is a provides like the
magnitude of the difference the
difference in the magnitude of each
simple enough that even Atheneum you
should be able to see this okay
questions
okay the simple complexity of this is
basically log 1 over beta over alpha
squared nu squared and there is a
different work of the guman all showing
that this is essentially optical so
first thing in order to turn successive
elimination into a private successive
elimination we make this na s algorithm
to differentially profit n is
straightforward application of the
sparse vector between the only slight
caveat that now carries a significant
meaning is that we do the query every
exponentially length interval and that
actually means something when we do it
with differential privacy because this
is what this reduces drastically the
number of queries that we make it
actually improves the cost moreover so
the sample complexity only increases the
added cost in addition to the cost of
the halting time the added cost in terms
of the sample complexity past that
original non private halting time I
still have to wait number of samples
which is loved one over beta over all
these other times and we sort of have a
matching band after some Lovelock
factors and again it's very simple
when one sample comes from a distributor
of renewal distribution of meaning you
and the other is this nu prime which is
precisely set in a way that 1 plus alpha
approximation of MU prime is no good for
a want to be at least on one minus alpha
approximation of Nu
so if I give an answer which is within
the range of 1 plus minus alpha to MU
prime it cannot be a good answer to me
basically the lower bound also writes
itself and you get that you have to wait
essentially this many steps
okay now will the private stopping bro
how do we solve the K multi-armed bandit
for a general okay the problem is that
we cannot apply the sparse vector
mechanism K times because the leading
arm a sample from the leading arm plays
a role in all of these K times and we
tried various ways of getting around
this and eventually we we apply this
with a D exponentially growing intervals
and halting when one of the reviewers
for the paper tells us well there is
actually no need for the sparse vector
mechanism and that review was absolutely
right so here is the solution to our
problem and the solution lies is in
these exponentially growing intervals
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to call these interval and
Apple we're setting the length of the
epic survey so that it captures any arm
where the sub optimality gap is greater
than 2 to the minus I and it's very
simple to see that these epochs are
exponentially growing in length they are
growing by at least four if you look at
the non-private part but at least two if
you look just at the private part so
what we do between epochs
is that we reset all counters we start a
brand new and that way each reward plays
a role only on a single epoch and I do
not need to budget my Epsilon I'm
partitioning the data but because of the
exponentially growing intervals well the
length of the epoch that cause causes me
to remove an arm is basically
proportional to the sum of all the
length of all the epochs preceding it so
the algorithm is simple enough that it
fits into a slide it may not look so
simple immediately but it is very very
simple all arm started viable I am
zeroing out the mean I'm setting my
epoch accordingly pulling all arms
setting the huffing bound and then I
basically do private histogram look at
the private histogram see which arms are
eliminated remove them all continue to
the next epoch and the analysis also
fits into a slide not really going go
into it but subject to all the noise not
getting out
we remove any on with the sub optimality
gap which is Delta of that epoch within
a certain number of steps and that means
that the total poles for an arm is
proportional to the length of the length
last-ever yes
what's the instant histogram over
histogram is over the reward of all the
arms of the chaos or the remaining
viable arms sorry
active arms okay
okay now the key point is as ever
because one the expected repair we have
to set beta is 1 over T so everything
that was logged one of her beta becomes
log T so the total regret is log T that
is the source log 1 over beta beta being
1 over T that's the source of Lochte won
over the sub optimality gap of this arm
x plus 1 over X and then you sum over
all K you get the matching non-private
regret bound and the private treatment
and again we also did experiments these
are actually the experiments with our
earlier version of this algorithm but
what's nice about this is the is that
you point out the shift you should
compare all the solids among themselves
and all the dollars among themselves so
this is the private youcb algorithm and
notice the smooth shape of it versus the
successive elimination problem and
notice how sharp it is basically hit
support up to a certain point I'm
pulling I'm pulling I'm pulling up then
I've removed them then it's no longer
viable
so it's flattened sir if I find it
interesting when the experiments back up
the math okay
okay because I'm going to skip to the
part I talked about in terms of all not
that I'm any qualified person to talk
about morality but and again these are
only my two cents so please don't higher
level or you there are two algorithms
used to be in successive elimination
that are equivalent non privately they
have the same regret bound and they're
both optimal and yet when we make them
differentially private one is noticeably
better than the other and why is that
so first ah rearrange the slider okay so
maybe ignore this part but here's a
question to you must it be like this
first is my question to you is the free
based algorithm optimal we know that the
lower bound again for the three based
algorithm is log t we don't know it has
to be polylactic we just know that it
doesn't meet their quick but even in an
adversarial setting can we argue that
it's Pawlik strictly poly log T and not
locked in now assuming disappeared
before this why are the two algorithm
different when I do the cost of
differential privacy it's because of
data dependence the UCP algorithm makes
the data dependent choice each and every
day looks at the upper confidence bound
I pulled this on pull this on oh now
this now is Chloe better that I pull
this one it makes a data dependent
choice each and every day
whereas successive elimination has
basically only K minus one meaningful
days in which declares I don't want to
pull arm 17 anymore
I don't pull arm 33 anymore and only
baby if you know these days the rest of
what the algorithm pulls is obvious
sequentially each arm after another
so we can think of it as successive
elimination being more simple than they
used to be algorithm and differential
privacy as a tool that prefers
simplicity that puts a quantitative
price to being simple asking is this
phenomena occurs in other data data
analysis test I would be very curious to
see that and secondly can we somehow
measure simplicity in a way that's
effective than a way that's gonna tell
me oh for different at least for
differential privacy this is going to be
better so this is the elegant way of
looking at here's the uglier way of
looking at it the uglier way of looking
at is to say well this successive
elimination algorithm is lazier than the
UCD it doesn't make a decision until it
gets an overwhelming evidence telling it
that this arm is bent only there it
declares or you know what I'm not going
to pull it on I've seen I pulled it
enough I know that it's going to be bad
so could it be that we are as
differentiated out the algorithm
designers prefer laziness should we
change the model into laziness in the
face of uncertainty because that costs
us less with this mall I'll conclude the
bibliography of all of those works not
very long you're welcome to read it
[Applause]
like reflecting on your your license
slide there I I guess once one cost with
these bandits I'll have to do a
gathering on their bones is that they
there's a sort of a bias introduced in
the estimates that they produce in terms
of their actually it could probably
provide a more precise statement but
effectively they end up providing biased
estimates for the arms that end up being
dropped early because they you know
basically the there's sort of a
selection effect where they so they tend
to drop arms that were they
underestimated the mean and the classic
multi on business yeah actually so if
you think of it as sort of as producing
doing multiple things and one of them is
to just produce estimates for the Mane's
of each of the arms at the end of the
algorithm in addition to the tacit snort
trying to do yes then it tends to under
this is without modification they tend
to underestimate the bias they tend to
produce biased estimates for the arms
that get dropped early and so they were
very they're like simple fixes to this
that involve gathering kind of twice as
much data or something like that but I
wonder if the that sort of a place where
its simplicity provides an advantage
demonstrable advantage I don't know yeah
well I mean even because the arguments
that or just gave us that you can
describe the entire transcript right but
that is that K steps - or an impression
down I guess I have to say that I don't
see off the top of my head the relation
between the compression and device so
even if the adaptive data analysis works
there's a link that's made between yeah
description like how much by it you know
if you give you some limitation on how
much excuse conditional probabilities I
think Aaron
let's tank organ
[Applause]